ils ont apporté des bonbons parce que
les profs c'est périssable inde - cette
rentrée trois classes au lieu de 4 à
roche lez beaupré la maternelle tourne
au grand cirque 31 à 32 élèves par
classe quand l'académie fixe la jauge
maximale à 30
vous avez tous une place assise ah bon
mais alors comment ils font ce qu'ils
n'ont pas de place pour une fois par
terre délivrer un enseignement à 31
élèves c'est pas possible
même si c'est en maternelle c'est là que
tout commence donc l'enjeu est quand
même important et parce qu on bouillonne
ça bouchonne la colère en bandoulière le
maire dénonce le tour de passe-passe de
l'académie qui dédouble les classes mais
divise les moyens il ya 800 postes de
800 places en france qui vont être
supprimés qui vont être qu'ils vont être
réduites ces 800 ponts chinois est
utilisé pour les mettre dans les classes
prioritaires donc donc je proteste à ces
pratiques et son fait qu'on mettait
qu'on fasse des classes prioritaire je
suis tout à fait d'accord mais qu'on
crée également des emplois qu'on crée
également des enseignants pour
accompagner pour encadrer tcc classe
prioritaire le plus rageant c'est que
l'école recense onze élèves en listes
d'attentes mais à deux ans et demi c'est
moche on compte pour du beurre
les parents aussi du coup nous on a
envie qu'elle entre à l'école parce
qu'on estime qu'elle est prête et leur
envie de le faire donc ça c'est bien on
a aussi un problème de garde puisque
nous on a une nounou qui est sympa donc
qui attend de voir un peu comment ça se
passe en fonction des heures qu'elle va
avoir ou pas et puis nous voilà on se
pose la question de savoir s'il n'y a
pas ici est-ce qu'il faut qu'on aille
dans le privé ce qui n'est pas du tout
notre souhait
les élus ont rendez vous à l'inspection
demain soir avec leur pétition leurs
arguments mais sont les bonbons